Más allá de algunos intervalos de pausa
continúan los bombardeos israelíes sobre
gaza y los lanzamientos de cohetes desde
la franja sin un camino claro hacia un
cese al fuego en la madrugada uno de
esos ataques aéreos israelíes sumó tres
muertos más superando ya la veintena de
fallecidos en los tres días que lleva
esta operación israelía en curso
bautizada como escudo y flecha
concretamos que al menos 15 de las
víctimas son civiles y que entre ellas
hay seis niños uno de los fallecidos en
el bombardeo de hoy en hand-yunis al sur
de la franja era un comandante de las
tropas de lanzamiento de cohetes de la
yihat islámica Palestina los otros dos
muertos también eran agentes según
Israel Aunque fuentes de seguridad
Palestina los identificaron como su
hermano y su sobrino y negaron que
fueran miembros de la yihad en este
contexto las conversaciones para llegar
a una tregua con la mediación de Egipto
aún no arrojan resultados Julie
edelstein titular del comité de defensa
del parlamento israelí ha dicho que hubo
acercamientos pero acusó a la llega de
querer imponer las condiciones para esta
tregua según reportes esta milicia
Palestina demanda garantías de que
Israel frene los llamados asesinatos
selectivos contra sus comandantes y que
devuelva el cuerpo de Jaden adnan el ex
miembro del grupo que murió en una
cárcel israelí tras 86 días de huelga de
hambre y cuya muerte dio inicio a esta
escalada unos pedidos que el gobierno
israelí por ahora no está dispuesto a
aceptar una señal de esta no
desescaladas la orden del ministro de
defensa Job galán a sus fuerzas
militares para que preparen nuevos
ataques y mantengan al máximo el nivel
de vigilancia la incógnita es Cuanto más
puede sostener la yihad islámica este
enfrentamiento sobre todo después de
haber lanzado más de 500 proyectiles y
Aparentemente haberlo hecho sin el apoyo
operativo de jamás y otros grupos
palestinos